Holy. The history of hyenas boys are in the building. Yes.
Yanis Pappas here. Chrissy D
we're here. We're. You guys are super gay.
You might be the only two guys gayer than me, then me and him on.
The internet. Here's the thing. Here's the thing with me.
Is, and Yonis we're in the same boat. I'm not,
I'm not a ho I'm not a hundred percent rosy. O'Donnell's Cruz.
I'm not a hundred percent gay, but I'm not a hundred percent sure.
That's what it is. So I could tell, I fall in love with men,
but I have sex with women. So you take that how you want.
Definitely liked girls, but it's like, if you're going to sit here and be like,
are you a straight guy? It's like, no, we say, Hey, Gabe.
Like some people are gay. Some people are straight. Uh, Chris is 100% disturbed.
Yeah. It comes in around here a lot with like, oh, who do you like?
Who's your dream girl?
Who's like the hottest girl in Hollywood. I'm like, I don't know. Ask me.
Who's hot guy. I'm like.
You got an hour. [inaudible] if you asked me, like,
who would I pay a million dollars to kiss on the lips? The answers, Tom Hardy,
Tom Hardy, a little punk saris. I'll get right on his lips immediately. Yeah,
sure. I want to make out with Rosario, Dawson and other beautiful,
but it's like, Tom Hardy just looks like he smells good.
I've watched that piece of movie with Reese Witherspoon and Chris pine, I think.
Oh, a hundred times over both of them. Absolutely.
It wasn't ready for war or something like that. Something about war. Oh yeah.
And it's, it's a, it's a terrible movie, but it's a awesome movie.
Cause the guys are so hot, dude.
The only way I get like truly super hard is if I listen to like a really
intellectual man, like we did an episode on history.
He knows when the other grass, Tyson, I was rock hard.
Like it was hurting my boss and I went home and I immediately tried to have sex
with a woman wasn't available. So I just jerked off to,
you said you're just a gay man. Who's waiting for his dad to die,
to come out of the closet. I got
[inaudible] tricep from push it down the gap. When you're talking about that,
where it's like,
I've reached a stage in my like porn watching career where I'm like,
I'll throw a dude searching,
exclusively search male porn sites. We did, we did research.
We did a neuroscience research on our podcast and it said that guys who watch
transport him, who liked that it's it's, it's actually,
it's not gay at all because what we're most attracted to as men is big and big
tips. So we get everyone's. Person's got a huge Dick and big. That's what
mine. That's all hat. That's old news. porn is way straighter than regular,
more boobs and and. This is just an extra Dick.
If I'm having sex with someone who's trans.
And she's pre-op. And uh, I just.
In your mind to making that gay, if you're doing a doggy style,
you just pretend like your Dick was so big. It popped through the other side.
You know, that's what it is. That's all it is.
[inaudible] you got a decent sized stick. You have about seven inches.
You said right now? No, no.
I'm I'm six and a six.
I might. Yeah. I'm six with my license where it says six, two, six,
five, and three quarters. But with air max on my Dick,
the six air max take you like another inch. I'm about,
I would say I'm about seven inches, eight with warts
because you got a seven inch piece. That's a pretty decent seven inches.
Not a woman has never told me, but she's had a problem with my Dick.
But that's different than seven inches. No one's ever said to me either,
but I don't have a 77 inch piece. I got pictures of it on my phone.
I can pull it right out. Let's check book. I can pull up my, I mean,
I love to see it. I would absolutely love to see your bullet right out.
It just does. We're off to the races, racist, KFC radio. What it is,
let me just find it. I gotta save them. My in, uh,
in my how's your job security here.
[inaudible] we're going to find it in sec. Yeah. It's a nice,
it's a nice night before I see it. He's got a, you go, you go hard. Dick pic.
You go, you go three quarters. You're about to see baby before you,
before you show.
Up, let me just tell you the type of disturbed Chris kid.
Chris is before I really knew him. Like we kinda knew each other. Like we,
he sent me a pic of Dick before.
Like we had a full conversation. If I could trust you or not. Yeah. Wow.
Show to the camera. That's illegally. Show it to the camera. Go ahead. Yeah.
go.com/kfc. That's a Coke can in his pants. What it is, fellas.
That's a zucchini that looks eggplant. It looks like,
I think you're underselling yourself. Yeah. That's full.
That's full. What the hell are you also grabbing your balls at the bottom?
There's the hall. I'll do that exact picture. I grabbed the ball. I don't know,
but I'm, I'm definitely on full board. Cause I listened to an Obama speech.
Real smart. Yo D and the D stands for
dude. No, no, no. So it's what do you walk around? All his confidence.
Cracking these jokes and. You got it. Big.
You just go in there and you have a good time. I'll be honest.
That's borderline inconvenient. I don't know if I'd want that.
I remember in high school, I had this kid who was on the hockey.
Team. Like, I mean, he had like a Pringle can and I was like, dude,
what the is that? Like, that makes no sense. And he was like, yeah,
like this hot chicken in our school. I tried to her in the jacuzzi this weekend.
And just like, she was like, no. And I was like, I.
Was like, I'm done. Well, you run it. You must run it. Who's the jacuzzi.
You going to get meningitis 17 year olds
who haven't heard of STDs and stuff like idiots. I used to.
Work in college. I used to work at a health club and they had hot pool and like,
uh, and gay guys, actually,
they have ways that they communicate and some of it would be like leaving
or something like that to let them know like that another gay guys there,
it was weird side.
My manager comes around. Like I would take a pebble and put it there.
And it's clean. You say.
You mean? Yeah.
They made me like, they're keys now. No, it's like actual.
He could've lied to me. He could have been gauging me. And he's a wild,
wild community. You know about bug chasing. No. Do tell,
let me tell you about bug chase. This is going to be, and it's a pit.
It's a movie about his own life. He's I'm Chrissy, the bug chase.
It's it's it's when a guy has sex, unprotected, bareback,
raw DZ sex with another guy who he knows has HIV
has the bug. And then they get off by chasing the HIV bug.
Whether they get it or not, they don't care.
It's about coming about the thrill of the bug.
Why that's like the most dangerous game humans,
what they do. Yeah. That's what they do.